.
RIGHT NOW.
E CORRESNDT KAITLAN LLS T
A TSE T NIGHT.
>> IT REALLY S WHEOK Y ENONE IST
N THE TOAT TO EMR.ERE SOME BIG O
THE  SEVERAL SS
CN PAN WILL WIN OUND
IS ACTHAT JOE BIDEN NAOW
D THATALLY HOPES OMOCRATS WORKE
ONE CENT ME ON
>> N YORK CMIRY EFT LONEH ILG
R CRATS.  FLORIDA VINGS
RUBIS SEATFOERRNOR AND W SM CRI
AB
E.
>>NO AUSE THIS GUY WANTSO BE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
OF AMERICA AND EVERYBODY.
HOWEVER, WHEN WET HIM ON  8T SH
HARRY, WE LED WITH THIF HINTS
BA T ELEIO
WE'VE SEEN IN NEW YORK ANDNG BA
WEEKS.
AT EXACTLY WEING?>> TALRKT SPOKL
INTRO R A LITTLT
SMAMOLINARO.BIY 1.5 POINTS02AT
RY JOE
T WHICH IS
QUITE RPN SP
HERE WE'RE TO GO TYO SOUISE
9 IS.
YES, THE REPUBLICAN WINS
BU T POINTS AND RG, WELLLESS THR
SN OUTPERFORMANCE FORDEMOCRAT 1
BASELINE IN NEW YORK 23, NHEYO
MIDTERM
OING BETTE YHEIN MRMCTION,
PARTICULARLY SINCE AER
>> THAT'Y SO OBVIOLYLATE JUNE.
OVTU DEMOCRATIC MARGIN
E
THORANDSEN.
HECEINT, NEW YORK 19, rd
ESNEAS, MOJOE BIDEN'S MARGIN
BYPOJU
BASELIHE ICLEA T
PAT RYAN REAY MOCRAT
CAMPAIRO T.RAL
HROUGHG RACEAW
OVERNIGHT.  WSPH OF A WERE TWO
POWERFUL CEEHA
EACH HE
JERR OVEHE MARGIN NOEN POINTS
>>K 10, YOU WILLOTIC
DAMAOBWA
SEDURING FIRST
T  AHEAD
TWT
OST OFT ARE E ABSENTEEALLO
DOING
PARTICULAR WONG OLDE
VOTERS, MYISN
LLT LLED IT YET.>> LET'S WAIT A
YORK 17,E SEEING MAYBEEND TOWARM
THE
>> YEAH, SO, YOUNO0 E SAW WAY R
IS ANOTHER RIVERA WHO
IS NOT OD GOLD MAB
VOTE
AB SE MAIN>> AND
TOO ASE CRIST N
DEMO BY ATIC
OFFICIALIKRIRY SEE Y
JOHN, WHAT DID SNIGHYOU?N JOHN
>> LOOK, I MEAN,F ALL,T SAW HAR
EMOCRA IS NOT TYPICALLY WHAT
YOM ELECTION
E TYPICALLY THPO S THE WIND ABA.
Y COULD BERE WAT
>> RTRNGASWELL FOR DEMOCRATS ASN
VEOBOVTUERD GAS NG DN
STRAIGHT DAYS ASE SIT HE
NE LABORAY, THGST ASFO THEOU BE
PARTY WITH A PRESIDENT W IS  FOT
MENTIEDHIISI'VE BEEHAON.
IND FLORIDTWBIG EST GHO REDISTCT
AND THEY G SHARD
BYGE WHOSEAT
LEGISLATURE TO PUT FRIDA RON De
MUCH MORPSIDED MAP IN HI
T LOPSIDED MAP IN THR ORIDA,AS W
HOUSEHOLD ME THE MESSA
>> ALL.L ABOU.
NOOOT'S SIIF
ACE ISE GOT
UNTYCUTIVES, ULSTE YOU HAVLINARE
S BLE, SANE
AND .
THCT THINU
SW THAT THDES ENVIRONMENTSOUUL
>> REPUBLICANS TN
CERTAINLY THOUGHT THEY COULD   H
WIN.
ON PE>>CRATS EXPLOIT THIS
GOINTHERE LIMIW WELL
LOOK, I MEAN, THISS UTG  GAP, BO
CONCERN ABOUT DEFENDINE OND,EN G
JOBS, ACY, BEING ONEN,
BEHIND IT.
ALSO YOU HAVE PRESIDENT'S ATING
ACCOMPLISHMEBUT IT IS ST
WE.
YO THE KIND
OF PENDUG ELONREOPPOSITION PAR Y
ATHE N
N THOP .
TO BE A ING MIDTERELECTIONL AT